[Music]
okay
in cheater cheater news pumpkin eater in
my like Oh pumpkin pie pumpkin pie is so
good and then you put the one and you
put the ice cream you put whipped cream
and ice cream
damn you fancy dude do you like it hot
or cold oh I like room temperature but
my new [ __ ] is how pure pumpkin pie oh
yeah because you didn't want to come the
Hawaii with us I try no it's at Ted's
bakery I like cold hunger but it's cold
Oh after the helpee a part of it yeah
and I want to try this pumpkin
cheesecake pie amazing where thing in
the world I've only had a homemade so I
don't know oh [ __ ] but you know what if
it's not seasoned and you can't get
pumpkin you could get sweet potato
pumpkin flavored stuff is so good we're
taking it back from the Starbucks girls
it's good it's real good I already took
that [ __ ] back oh no but that's a basic
ass [ __ ] yeah a basic business yeah
okay submitted by murder mystery Oh your
favorite favorite it I don't know is it
oh no you like that forensic [ __ ] I
figured it'd be this I don't like it
anywhere because it makes me sad okay
well I don't know that's news to me
won't update we were BFFs I know sorry I
forgot to text you
here are the seven traits most cheaters
have in common
oh my god tell me yeah sorry one they
like to [ __ ] number two they need a
validation Oh number three they insecure
school cheaters are like relationship
live cheaters oh yeah not relationship
number one they got bad grades number
two
dude one thing definitely has to be like
if their parents weren't like together a
lot like if they never got to see like a
happy like super functional marriage
like that sometimes that's like
definitely a thing my parents were
really happy up until the point my dad
left out of nowhere oh yeah my dad was
never around but I don't cheat but like
that's like a thing - that's like
definitely things tears behind that
smile
first of all starts up with their saying
that according to a 2010 to 2017 General
Social Survey issued by the Institute
for Family Studies they found that 20%
of men and 13 percent of women have had
sex with someone who was not their
spouse well married and so they're
saying here that a lot of the cheaters
they have common personality traits and
they're saying so for the first one here
is cheaters like to keep their personal
lives private Oh so then people that are
more open they can't hold a lion yeah
also let's not forget the best
statistics that 20% of men and 13% of
women admit admit it hurts my heart
that's the key yeah so they're saying
that Tudor secrets can often be revealed
through the recent calls lists and their
text messages or private folder in the
email but if your partner has a locked
phone and that's a dead giveaway that
they're trying to hide something for
sure what's the definition of cheating
for these people is it sex no so they
also said that cheating can mean
different things for different people
it's just however you take it so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just sex
it could be like talking to someone
intimately never even having physical
contact but if your partner would
consider that cheating then that is
cheating mmm yeah my rule has always
been if your significant other was
reading what you're saying or watching
you do whatever you're doing and they
would not like it then it is cheating
like that's a good rule yeah but what if
she crazy and it's like she's like she's
like why you talking to your mom so much
and not me you got I've known someone
like that you're her boyfriend they were
at the checkout line and I would
sisters huh they're at the checkout line
and then her boyfriend was like oh damp
from a magazine and he was like oh damn
she's really pretty and then she just
got so butthurt because he said a
celebrity was attractive
yeah like she was just like how could
you like in front of Geo like why did
you do that like what you want to go
[ __ ] her and then I was just like no I
would have [ __ ] poked a hole through
the magazine start [ __ ] in front of
her
yeah the groceries never buy the
magazine first oh and if supply the
National Enquirer something like ladies
magazine well not gonna promote that you
or the next person is right here they're
saying that cheaters will rarely if ever
call you by your name it'll decide to
call you like baby sweetheart sweetie
and they're also mentioning here did you
guys I receive John Tucker Must Die yeah
that movie yeah so in that movie he had
like a shits and a girlfriends and he'd
never once called them by their name and
that's an order it's like not mix up the
name oh this like a player cheater cuz
it sounds like a player like a a person
that just plays people yeah but those
are gonna check those are the ones that
sweep you off your feet and then I'm
horrible cuz I [ __ ] suck at that [ __ ]
so unromantic Oh
cheaters know how to lie and know how to
lie well cuz they have to keep up with
their lives they'll even set up their
lives for the future for example saying
that there they will like all of a
sudden that their job they have like a
[ __ ] ton of more work and that they're
not gonna be able to spend as much time
with you because they're gonna have more
work to be doing and that's how they'll
set up their lives for the future poker
players or secret agents next one they
aren't necessarily unavailable but
they're not exactly available either
this happened to my friend um recently
he was like oh man I don't know what it
is but she's just so busy all the time
and then like I just can't get a
straight answer from her oh no I don't
know if she's being completely honest I
don't know I I really tell
that you know heartbreaking yeah cuz
like I think everyone that's been
through it they know what that feels
like it's like they're either not that
into you
yeah or they're confused cuz then it's
like you're still [ __ ] but then
you're not sure where you are well like
there's just a lot of like mystery going
on and they're not being straightforward
and because they don't want to like
leave you they don't want to like lose
you as it as in as an option yeah and
then the next thing we know is I'm
scrolling through Instagram and she's
kissing this guy that's not my friend
and she's professing her love to him in
a different country and I just remember
he dropped her off at the airport to go
to that [ __ ] country oh my god you're
so stupid about this thing okay is that
we find out later that she saw a picture
of him with a girl which is platonic
relationship they're just working
together and she's she felt jealous from
that so she decided to expose her love
with this other guy to make him jealous
Wow oh my god holiday like 16 I know
that sounds like some high school she's
she's and she's like I don't think she's
21 yet oh my god yeah yeah that does but
this is the stupid part she thinks she's
gonna come back and get with my friend
again you don't know your friend sounds
like yeah he sounds like he died someone
put me through it you broke my heart
[ __ ] with my home you felt that when
I saw that post I'm a spirit I was like
oh [ __ ] no and I was like you better not
[ __ ] get back with her and he's like
I won't and I'm like even if that puts
it good he's gonna do it you better
watch out bad there's plenty of all that
booty yeah yeah how old is he
mid-twenties I think yeah 18 you don't
know what you're doing like I shouldn't
even been allowed to leave the house but
that's what that's what I was like man
this is this is heartbreaking
I could I could understand the mentality
because I have a lot of female friends I
like I've talked to her giving advice to
or like yada yada yada and like boy they
are [ __ ] crazy okay
Oh
yes yes 18 I say 18 to 22 were you that
crazy at 18 you were like here so I
think I was like I wasn't that crazy I
mean I understood crazy a lot of friends
that were created crazy right I dated
crazy but then as soon as there was
crazy I dropped them yeah you had the
girlfriend that was on parole that's
crazy and you weren't dating for a while
yes kind of crazy
no she so she had a probation officer
and this I knew she was down for her
[ __ ] together but then afterwards she
was too crazy because there's crazy like
under control crazy if you have a parole
officer you don't have control yeah yeah
[ __ ] crazy yeah that's all you need
yeah okay she's down for her [ __ ] and I
needed a chick what is that mean like
she's down but then she's down for her
shape I'm like it's good like you fight
if I killed someone sure help me cover
it up or if I have to run away from the
cops I can either at her house she's
like a body kind of girl but then she's
an angel when it comes to not [ __ ] a
bunch of other guys yep
next one is they tend to rationalize
their behavior despite whether it's
right or wrong they'll say that like
they'll try to pretty much say like they
have these needs in order to cheat so
like they'll pretty much blame it on the
other partner saying like it well it's
your fault for why I need to do this
that makes sense because the ego is
never wrong in the bigger your ego the
more clever it becomes to figure out
ways on why everybody else is wrong but
you but that's with anything though
that's like no one that this is what I
believe like so like everyone's like oh
that person's bad this is a bad person
right the the problem is no one realizes
that most people live life thinking that
they are the hero like no one does [ __ ]
even murderers no one does it thinking
like oh they're doing something so wrong
they're always justifying [ __ ] in their
twisted mind
oh yeah like how like people to do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] they're like they have a
manifesto as to why they did yeah or
like everybody the world is so corrupt
that's why they need to cleanse it or
like you know like
Ultra villain that wants to destroy the
world yeah I need to [ __ ] this girl so
the girls know the dick size doesn't
matter
yeah like okay you got that that's
exactly an excellent it tutors instinct
is to beat around the bush if and when
they're asked about the person they're
cheating on you with so they'll deflect
conversation the door they'll minimize
their actions whenever you confront them
like hey or you've been spending a lot
of time with this one co-worker and
they'll be like but we're just friends
that's one the last one here is cheaters
are impulsive they can't resist taking
that risk despite what it might cost
them hmm
so there's ruled by power and drawn to
risk hmm that's so true because I bet
you like if most guys in a relationship
where to somehow like maybe they're
traveling alone and then they opened up
their hotel room they're tired to get
out of shock and then what they see on
the bed is a girl just bent over with
her ass cheek spread she's hot as hell
me she's in the maid outfit she's got a
booty like spread she's like oh welcome
home welcome home master and is like oh
[ __ ]
then you got a do man [ __ ] then you're
just like damn giggle II know I just
thought oh you're you just took a shower
you know you're just you're about to
[ __ ] knock out you're in the hope
you're there at the hotel room you can't
go off guard you're just trying to get
that last bit of water out of here if I
had a port and nobody else like is there
a camera hidden cat what the [ __ ] but
what do you do you do man [ __ ] hmm but
but I don't know like most guys are
never tested in that in that position
you know you got a you got a guy's got a
by a hooker they got a pickup a girl you
have to do the effort right but what is
it just came like out of nowhere like
God just went had to and in like 10
hookers just came out of nowhere from
one at that and
yeah whatever what if you're like hungry
and in your post mate you go like hey
post mates bring me some food right and
then post mates is like this hot-ass
like [ __ ] Halloween costume horny
lady and she's like boobs suck on these
for [ __ ] dinner like woah oh she's
like oh they didn't have your order of
milk yeah I want to know what to do cuz
I never get presented with that type of
test I'm gonna say opportunity I want to
do it I don't want to because I feel
like someone's watching what's said he
doesn't want to but he didn't say he
wouldn't do it I'm not gonna say no like
I just never been tested and I'm gonna
try my hardest to resist but it's like
my mind's telling me no but it's like
what what happened
all I'm saying is that guys aren't
tested like that which they should be
then then you know how good your love is
that's just should be in the valves
actually because the house is always
like some [ __ ] that's never gonna happen
yeah they should tell like a common
thing right yeah but it's salt like we
all we all die we all get sick like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] like of course everything
is gonna be good like of course the
relationships gonna be gonna be good if
it's it's not tested you know why bowels
are so basic you're supposed to take
care of your woman you're supposed to
take care of each other you're supposed
to love them till death that's why
you're getting area right yeah what have
you said if there was a girl that's
naked yeah that's over [ __ ] butt
cheeks take it out yeah
wet ass [ __ ] she says never [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
that's what the preset say I mean he's
supposed to say hell yeah hell yeah I
never aged and I stayed my age and you
became 80 and this girl was hot as [ __ ]
and she started tickling my balls I
would never let her [ __ ] suck my dick
I would love
at Faro now go back to your [ __ ]
grandma ass and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you
because I'm Benjamin Button Wow all
right so the way that they finish this
list here though is that they're saying
that in truth cheaters are deeply
insecure people who feel flawed unloved
angry and ironically are robbed
something that they didn't that they
needed emotionally in life as a child so
in other words it's not used them of
course in their personality traits I
can't handle this very traditional I
don't appreciate that you like love
[Music]